[Música]
y yo en el momento que hablamos sobre el
resurgir de la ciudad
yo diría bueno pues
el primer caso es como decir bueno cope
donde viene o por qué resurgir pueblo y
esto básicamente viene
ya ves a miguel no necesariamente a 2006
2 mil 399 torreón y el centro empiezan a
tener una serie de decadencia
en algún momento sector real era la
ciudad por excelencia del porfiriato y
en 1900 897 es como las fiestas fechas
en las que empieza como centro
poblacional de 3000 personas que había
en este lugar visto en este resultó real
de pronto en 1910 había casi 40.000
personas este boom económico este cruce
de ferrocarriles que ya todos conocemos
estas avenidas del río nazas y aguanaval
las lagunas que tristemente ya no
existen
bueno pues era una ciudad muy muy
boyante aquí tuvimos adelantos
tecnológicos que no llegaron a méxico y
hasta un poco tiempo después aquí se es
un tranvía diagonal línea aérea y la
primera las primeras detalles con luz
eléctrica y bueno pues así fuimos
creciendo
nosotros ahora acá en el instituto y el
museo que se muestra la moneda en un
edificio que está aquí del banco de
méxico y bueno el banco méxico no tenía
de esas instalaciones más que 349
ciudades del país y esa esa sucursal del
banco de méxico no sufra durango no se
puede a saltillo o capitales sino que se
vino aquí en torreón precisamente por
esa bonanza por esa bonanza económica
que teníamos y obviamente líneas gracias
o principalmente por el tema del algodón
y bueno la avenida morelos era una
avenida muy importante se fundó en 1920
está a punto de cumplir 100 años las
palmas que ustedes ven ahí están a punto
de sí nos cumplieron 100 años que no es
nada usted diga no es poca cosa perdón y
era el romano de rolo funda nació peace
garza en un momento en el que suceden
cosas también como en esta revolución
edificios como la casa mudéjar en fin un
montón de edificios que se empiezan a
hacer precisamente
esto es a principios del siglo 20 y
entonces es una representación un poco
de lo que era el espíritu de torre a un
pueblo de ver hacia adelante el progreso
etcétera sin embargo bueno pues
empezamos a tener problemas y empieza a
haber problemas de mala administración
en el campo de corrupción de mal uso de
los como se llama de los créditos y
entonces de en 1910 tener una persona
como rafaela erógena que bueno pues el
nombre de ella es que este museo
funciona o tiene el nombre perdón
una persona que desde su oficina podría
modificar el precio del algodón a nivel
internacional simplemente con cerrar o
abrir los mercados pero el producto que
ellos generaban en sus ranchos
bueno pues llegamos a casi sembrar de
sembrar casi y bueno pues imagínense la
cantidad de hectáreas que se sembraban
pero tengo el dato que en 2000 había
sembrada 53 mil hectáreas de algodón y
ahora bueno un pico un sótano en el cual
llegaban cáncer 13.000 y ahora tenemos
un promedio de 18 mil hectáreas que se
siembran de algodón otra crisis
importante es la crisis de las maquilas
de pronto llegaron como la panacea de la
solución de los problemas laborales y
económicos de la región y pues yo no sé
si ustedes se acuerdan pero aquí había
hasta luiz yo sabía donde decían que la
mezclilla del país de aquí de la laguna
de gómez palacio en específico para
coraje de los torreonenses porque todo
mundo ya no banano más en gómez en toda
la laguna
bueno pues en los 90 se cae eso por
crisis económicas etcétera entonces
volvemos a traer pero fue como una
especie de descenso pues de ideas y poco
a poco y eso fue generando que bueno
pues que esperar alejando empezó a ver
también una especie de
y cómo podemos decirles de
mudanza de los negocios de aquí el
centro hacia hacia él hacia el oriente
hacia el sur hacia el norte por todos
estos trabajos o todas estas como
podríamos decirlo cómo generar
beneficios serían reyes hacia otras
partes de la ciudad entonces empieza a
mudarse empieza a desocuparse a mí me
tocó muchas veces de seguir a caminar a
las maquinitas enamoré los los papás los
abuelos iban y se conocían en la morelos
etcétera puerto entonces empezamos a
tener una decadencia y esto se agudiza
después con la crisis de inseguridad que
tuvimos
y yo decía que a veces era muy
complicado caminar siempre yo muchos
años he vivido en el sector no normal en
todo lo que tengo viviendo el torneo
nunca más afortunadamente no ha pasado
nada en el centro
y eso fue generando una situación muy
complicada entonces qué es lo que sucede
en torreón bueno pues que datos como
esos edificios como el hotel salvador
éstos este edificio monterrey que es
como de los últimos y es como nuestro
rascacielos es el edificio más alto del
torreón cuando tembló aquí en morelia no
sé qué hace muchos años todo mundo salió
despavorido porque medio se sintió el
temblor lo que les decía esta crisis que
empieza a tener su inicio yo lo ubico
más o menos por ahí de los años 80 y
marcos atrás 2016 porque es cuando
empieza a darse está este calle la
percepción de inseguridad
y bueno esto es de las cosas terribles
que nos pasan acá y creo que a todo el
mundo tuvimos gente amigos a nosotros
mismos nos pasaron nos enteramos de
matanzas de robos de levantones de
balaceras este número de homicidios en
esa curva como de algo muy tranquilo que
bueno normalmente eran crímenes
pasionales
más alto y se muere gente bueno de
repente saltamos hasta 825 personas
muertas solamente en 2002
esto aquí a una cuadra yo creo que a
todo mundo le sucedió eso la vio lo
vieron modelando inicial
tres días después de justo una balacera
que se vio aquí en el centro de una
persona y justo porque estaban allí
apostados estos estos policías federales
pues hay otro contexto y de pronto
empiezan a suceder cosas en 2012
un tema
la elección en la que ensayó a veces que
resultando elegido desde que peña nieto
pero también otro parte aguas o el
referente importante para nosotros nos
empezamos a enterar que se quería hacer
algo en amor en los que un paseo que hay
40 millones que va a costar tanto que
aquello el otro y en la plaza mayor
ahí está nuestro
muy honorable pri moreira primero y
bueno pues el dato era que iba a costar
500 millones de pesos y se iba a acabar
a fines de 2010
la obra y la realidad es que se duplicó
casi el presupuesto y que se tardó más
de tres años de lo que se había dicho y
eso no es lo principal sino que lo
principal es que en todos estos terrenos
que vemos aquí alrededor de esta planta
pues hubo información privilegiada y si
yo sabía que iba a suceder ese proyecto
bueno pues iba contigo y te decía vaya
cuánto cuesta tu casa
pues no sé no tiene precio los 100 mil
veces te doy 200 mil
se lo compraban pero esas personas se lo
vendían al gobierno en dos tres cuatro o
cinco de esas más entonces por eso es
que el proyecto se va inflando por un
lado por otro lado con todo el tiempo en
el que estuvo cerrado de esa avenida de
esa zona
bueno pues se fue muriendo imagínense yo
creo que muchos aquí les recordamos este
recordamos esta situación alrededor de
la de la plaza mayor lo que es la frase
mayor que me acuerdo
ocasiones durante todos utilizaron
martínez y era una situación así como
muy triste entonces cuando empezamos a
darnos cuenta de esto este hombre que te
que esa declaración en ese entonces era
presentar la cama de comercio
ahora el regidor en esta administración
fue secretario de economía como premio
para entonces éste él decía vamos a
hacer este proyecto
que va a durar cinco meses y que nos
vamos a gastar eso bueno ya con ellos
después nos dijeron que el costo 120
millones se tardaban dos años entonces
nosotros dijimos a ver este con toda
esta dinámica de pensamiento y que la
inseguridad y las marchas y desierto
tengo que decir surgen redes del
desierto
dijimos tenemos que hacer algo porque
otra cosa que de pronto es porque nos
podemos hacer las cosas
o sea de pronto yo yo yo escucho a mucha
gente que se va de la ciudad porque el
torreón no tiene cosas que hacer porque
no hay profesión obviamente se agua y
saben en ese momento 2012 había una
estadística que decía 80 por ciento de
los jóvenes entre 18 y 25 años se
quieren ir de la ciudad
y porque mientras está en problemas y
aparte uno sabe que la forma de trabajar
de los políticos normalmente no es como
muy transparente y clara y en buena lid
como sucede más cuando hay tanto dinero
involucrado más cuando hay una guerra
del narco a deudas de ti y por qué
porque nos vamos a regar y para mí era
algo tan sencillo como
de una ciencia de méxico hace ya unos
años donde vemos al iraq aquí estaban
mis tíos mis primos la alberca de las
paletas wind y la nieve el chepo el agua
celis el centro de la plaza de armas de
la medida los elotes mis abuelos
entonces eso en algún punto
pues se te va metiendo la sangre pues
está metiendo la sangre empiezas a
tomarle amor a las calles a mí
particularmente estaría muy muy muy
peculiar está la vida en la ciudad de
méxico todo gris lluvias muchos arroyos
obviamente pero no había una calle
similar o por lo menos yo viví mi corta
novedades potencia de méxico
y cuando empezamos a hacer las cosas no
crean que todo esto que les va a poner
ya lo teníamos así a ver esto lo que
vamos a la realidad es que fuimos
haciéndolo poco a poco y nos fuimos
dando cuenta conforme fuimos leyendo
conforme nos fuimos conociendo a gente
que lo que queríamos hacernos fotos era
esto a veces nos decían a diana léale
personas quién hacer política o este
movimiento que es político que quieren y
nosotros le decíamos a todos si
realmente si es político pero es
político desde este punto de vista la
raíz griega de la de la palabra política
punto ciudad y es asunto de los
ciudadanos y para la foto será hacer y
ayudar a construir la ciudad
cuando suceden todo esto estamos en una
situación de crisis y de seguridad
y nos dimos cuenta de esto y como digo
esto no me llevó esta frase que dice que
si quieres ir rápido camina solo para mí
eso es una de las cosas más importantes
y luego aumentar un pequeño gol pero
creo que es algo que también me gustó de
esta inversión en la que ahora trabajo
que es trabajo en equipo torrado será en
equipo justo
si corres pues no puedes llegar bien
rápido puedo
si quieres la frase si si quieres y
rápido camina solo si quieres llegar
lejos ve acompañado y creo que eso fue
mucho del éxito de morelia no empezamos
seis personas
entonces alrededor de esto se empezó a
crear una comunidad nos hicimos seis
personas empezamos y tuvimos iniciativa
cerramos la calle y 14 cuadras y el
primer modelando bueno había 300 400
personas que para mí ya fue unas
ganancias yo me recuerdo andando en
bicicleta la avenida morelos toda sola
sin coches
para mí y ahora que disfruto todavía más
el tema de caminar pottermanía tan tan
tan ajetreada como la vía morelos de
repente sola fue algo así como uno de
esos momentos que
y llaman de paz pues entonces yo solo no
lo hubiera hecho
cada quien empezó a hacer su tarea
éramos porque hicimos el diseño
rubalcaba
jose gonzalez y yo y entonces esa
pequeña comunidad cita lo que pesó fue a
generar otras comunidades
el primero en hablar de algo caminar
constantemente la bebida y platicar con
la gente de la calle de los que tienen
locales empezar a hacer alianzas y yo
recuerdo ahorita este momento que dice
uno de los momentos de la porquería
revistaba en algunos momentos en la
avenida si no es que todos los
morelianos junto con ruth germán y toda
su todo su trouppe de palabra cada hora
y alrededor de eso también empezamos a
generar otra comida que es la de los
artistas como keith activo porque para
mí creo que es como el espacio en el
cual todas estas personas tienen un
momento generamos modelando los confluir
complejos ahí en esa mesa en ese espacio
bueno porque dentro de las múltiples
actividades creo que es la que más me ha
gustado y todo esto de hacer la
programación de ver con qué hacíamos en
algún momento dijimos bueno que hacemos
llegamos y cerramos la calle nomás
nosotros cerramos y nos vemos a capón
rebeldes y a ver autoridades hagas un
lado y allí en la práctica se decidió no
hacerlo así porque porque era como muy
disruptivo
y dijimos bueno vamos a empezar a pedir
permisos pedimos permiso oficialmente
así al central del ayuntamiento queremos
hacer esta actividad
calles queremos cerrar la apoye nos
convidan y bueno se fue degenerando y
cuando cuando mezclas o cuando les dije
buenos hay como cada quien tiene sus
estilos y el mío particularmente dentro
de la onda de la música electrónica ción
para cómo tratar de que tú digas tu
viaje sin darte cuenta que fueron 100
canciones y creo que de esa manera es
como para nosotros se convalidó
empezamos a ser un una mezcla entre una
época muy complicada muy difícil
mediante una canción que pudiera ser
esta actividades de estas actividades
que hacíamos una vez al mes más bien un
permiso y eso sin ser tan disruptivos a
lo mejor como un zeta capón donde sube y
baja sino que importa cómo son los dicen
nada sino que al contrario fue algo tan
suave que de repente las autoridades no
se dieron cuenta y cuando empezaron a
hacer su proyecto pues había 15 mil
personas en la calle o 30.000 como
pueden tercer aniversario entonces ya no
era tan difícil y ahora sí qué
darle palmaditas a los señores que están
haciendo cosas a la manera de iglesia si
estás haciendo algo no no no
nosotros estamos ayudando a 30.000
personas a la calle tenemos tantos
comerciantes que nos respaldan entonces
tú no vas a poder llegar a hacer las
cosas como normalmente lo haces tienes
que cambiar tu proyecto y tienes que
cambiarlo de acuerdo a lo que nosotros
como la calle como los que vivimos en la
calle no podemos la podemos ir es que
reflejando en su proyecto bueno aquí
este es el último equipo de morelia ando
adelante bueno estamos porque jose y yo
y otras ventajas que cuando llegan en el
episodio número 7 demore le ando cambiar
la imagen gráfica
actualiza y moderniza nuestro logo y
wenzhou trata estrictamente del año
pasado falleció fernando aldo gustavo
que fue el que se le ocurrió la idea de
comprar una lámpara cuando me están mes
mes tras mes les decíamos a verla que
esta oscura no camina nadie está la del
poniente de poniente del amor eros y
joyas pues compremos una lámpara e mail
que está en geográfico y vanessa que
también caminando y con su fuerza
también nos y cuando empezamos nos
decían mira lo que tiene que hacer es
hacer un diagnóstico hagan encuestas
vean de qué se trata
investiguen hagan los estudios y luego
ya y nosotros que hemos a ver si hacemos
eso nunca lo hemos asientos fue tratar
de hacer las cosas rápido no no no algo
por ahora
un punto de vista burocrático y tienes
que generar mucha planeación pero en ese
momento tienes la capacidad de hacerlo
hay que hacerlo y yo creo que esto es
importante también estas dos palabras
son importantes para mí la sincronía ay
sí
yo veo como una sincronía entre cosas
malas cosas buenas que al final fueron
dando muchas cosas y se fueron generando
causas y efectos que permitieron que
ahora sucedan con somos lo que estás
haciendo enamorados por y por otro lado
la empatía en cuanto a saber qué es lo
que piensa la otra persona saber qué
quiere que lleva a otra persona sepa qué
es lo que tú quieres y de esa manera
poder encontrar mejores soluciones a los
problemas y algo que me llamó mucho la
atención es que sus dos palabras son
femeninas es de género femenino y creo
que habla un poco también de esta acción
en la cual el peatón es uno de los más
válidos el feminismo ahora habla de esta
inclusión y de esa de equilibrar
los desequilibrios valga la redundancia
entre el machismo entre el masculino y
el género masculino y femenino y bueno
esto a mí me dio mucho mucho la atención
porque quiere decir que de alguna manera
desde ese género género hacíamos una
acción nos organizamos no fuimos los
únicos para su paso y suena 29 que son
las señales que siguen muy activas es
cierto la excusa un poquito tiene ese
orden cronológico consejo cívico
modelando la bueno yo te quiero renacer
distinto colónica personal a nivel
nacional fueron muchas organizaciones
que fueron surgiendo en ese año que de
alguna manera también formaron una
comunidad de comunidades
a mí me daba muchas sorpresas por
ejemplo en este tercer aniversario que
haya habido 30.000 personas y el equipo
de morelia no éramos básicamente 10 o a
lo mejor hasta 20 personas incluimos a
los tránsitos cmc algo tan sencillo tan
sorprendente perdón y yo lo llamaba un
poco como anarquía pues no la anarquía
no es ir a quemar puertas del palacio
federal y hacer pintas ya que llenó la
anarquía es dejar que la sociedad se
vaya equilibrando según reglas no
escritas o momentos no escritos y creo
que es lo que pasa va modelando porque
al final y no estamos ahí atrás de cada
persona durante las no sé cuántas
decisiones que tuvimos nunca tuvimos un
incidente grave que algún loco en
vehículo lo que quiera
tales quítense o asaltos o accidentes
fue algo muy afortunada y que es parte
de esta sincronía que les comento
y obviamente este era un tema importante
ahora todos estos temas como le dije lo
hicimos sacando pero para nosotros el
primer punto y siempre la clave era
vamos a posicionarnos para que cuando
llegue este proyecto de espacio morelos
nos van a tener que pedir a nosotros
permiso como ciudadanos
el primer primer mariano y si se fijan
bueno esta por ahí lo debe tener
y este era otro tema importante con todo
este tema de la decadencia de la
violencia fuimos dejando las calles
fuimos dejando las plazas vamos dejando
los comercios aproximadamente 1.400
talentos en 5 años aproximadamente se
visitan mil personas en cinco años torre
mantiene 662 mil personas según el
último censo del inegi entonces en cinco
años casi toda la ciudad de torreón
camino las moreras
en esos momentos y parte digo yo no sé
quién es de aquí alguien ha estado en
morelia no levanten la mano
pues casi todos casi todos y creo que la
gente lo que dice es un pañuelo sasemar
y landó precisamente la cambia y la
caída cambio su dinámica y es muy
difícil que vuelva a separarse de eso
otra vez por las sincronías que se
dieron en ese momento
fue algo como esas chispas que se siente
algo pues la chispa se apaga y siguen
otras cosas por ahí aquí enfrente de me
da mucho gusto siempre el frente del
banco de méxico hay cinco árboles
mesquites hermosos
los sembramos en esta ocasión fue como
en el segundo tercer moldeando y ahora
son unos árboles gigantes es más o menos
lo que nos gastamos en ese entonces en
2015 espacio moro del paseo colon costar
50 mil pesos
ese es el proyecto famoso imagínense
esto era lo que se quería sacar de
alguna manera sarao divito aunque
ustedes dicen aumento porque no queremos
hacer ahí el humito ni avanzar box en
nuestra calle bueno porque para empezar
no nos vamos tan lejos aquí hay cinco
seis siete cafeterías importantes que
pudieran ser o una tienda ancla y en ese
espacio porque sacamos asada si tenemos
alguna tienda de local no sé es éste yo
no sé se cambió el proyecto y se hizo de
otra manera no nos escuchaban 100% y un
momento no se quedaron así y ahí se
quedan no acabe aquí cuando pusimos las
luces un amigo decía goyén y asiste pues
fíjate que yo lo que veo es que ustedes
lo que hicieron es que esta línea del
tiempo la movieron
o así como se ve en el de arriba la
movieron y olió sabes que si a lo mejor
la movimos unam y tradicional porque él
es a la movieron la micro de encima de
esa línea de tiempo pero luego yo creo
que la movimos de esta manera y si
ustedes se fijan pues a lo mejor aquí no
se alcanza a ver la separación pero a lo
largo del tiempo digo ahí estaba el
ejemplo que encontré en la red cuadrada
como ese pero creo que a lo largo del
tiempo esa separación del cambio de la
historia de alguna manera se va
magnificando y bueno pues se puede ver
en lo que estás haciendo ahorita
entonces bueno que si hay un resurgir yo
creo que si nos queda a nosotros seguir
haciendo ese cambio y yo creo que ahora
le va a pasar repito unos números por
ejemplo en 2016 la percepción de
seguridad según barómetro era de 5.2 en
el 2018 estamos en el 5.9 la precisión
social sobre la seguridad pública en la
laguna en 2017
7 % ahora es de 54.8 una mejoría pequeña
y creo que ya va a terminar y si puede
haber un resurgir hay de repente yo
mismo estando en los centros teniendo a
cargo centros culturales bibliotecas y
museos de repente te llegan en noticias
y calificó la cosa como que si va pero
de pronto puede degradarse entonces
tenemos retos como ciudadanos como
miembros de una gran comunidad de
torreón miembros de una gran comunidad
que es la laguna y entre los retos
principales que yo encuentro es uno que
mencionaba aquí
édgar que es el ser más incluyente y más
inclusivos en la infraestructura y
también que sea más accesible para
personas con discapacidad y con los
peatones de pronto toda la
infraestructura está hecha para el
vehículo y el peatón es el elemento más
importante y el claro de ejemplo de eso
para mí
en este proyecto boliviano en el cual
miles de gentes cientos de miles de
gentes salieron a caminar la y de alguna
manera con esa caminata con esa ruedita
de morelia cndh o con piecitos este
con nuestra energía logramos abrir ese
canal es a viena que sale de la ciudad y
logramos revivir la entonces caminamos
nuestras ciudades podemos la en el caso
del gas o andemos en bici pero caminemos
la llegamos comunidad compremos con
nuestros vecinos con nuestras tiendas
locales
visitamos el centro y no le tengan miedo
yo creo que muchos que estamos aquí los
hayamos venido pero digan a los demás
que el centro seguro y que hay muchas
cosas
bueno pues muchas gracias y gracias otra
vez a todo el equipo del electro
[Música]
[Aplausos]